so this is great this is this is a
really serious thing but it also
includes a really funny clip there was a
debate audience that broke out in an
uncontrollable fit of laughter when a
Republican Senate candidate tried to
claim that Donald Trump has been quote
standing up to Russia which of course he
hasn't been doing he's been doing the
opposite of that I'm gonna play the clip
for you and this is part of the sort of
Orwellian Newspeak where they have
straight-up started to say the opposite
of what is going on and this is now
leaking over to Senate candidates who
are trumpets including Republican Senate
nominee Corey Stewart who's running in
Virginia against incumbent Democratic
senator Tim Kaine and Tim Kaine of
course during the debate he talked about
Russian aggression during the 2016
election undeniable at this point he
talked about Russian aggression during
Barack Obama's presidency including the
invasion of Crimea downing an aircraft
over Ukraine here is how Corey Stewart
responded and of course laughter from
both the audience and Tim Kaine and
response it was noticeably silent when
the Russians shot down a Malaysian
airliner when President Obama was in
office he was noticeably silent when the
Russians invaded the Crimea when
President Obama was in office we have a
president who was standing up to the
Russians and now senator Kaine now we
have
now we have senator Kaine now we have
senator Kaine I actually think that a
straight-up uncontrolled fit of laughter
is a pretty damn good way to challenge
these types of nonsense claims it's
actually kind of powerful imagine if
when candidates say such ridiculous
things instead of trying to fight it
point by point when they've thrown out
10 lies in a minute and convince people
which you won't be able to do right if
the entire room simply starts laughing
hysterically at the obvious lies and
then you just move on it starts to take
on an air of this childish ignorance
from these people is so dumb and so
inaccurate that it's actually funny it
doesn't even require a response and this
is not normally my view right my view is
ad homonyms aren't arguments and you
need to take the arguments on at their
core but when the arguments are not even
based in fact and this is something that
over the weekend a number of interesting
articles were written in the context of
Holocaust denial and how Holocaust
denial should be managed on online
forums because you're fundamentally not
going to be able to actually fight it
with facts because the people who are
committed to Holocaust denial are not
going to be influenced by facts what
about just laughing and if they can say
it themselves right something like Trump
is tough on Russia without cringing or
getting red in the face how are you
going to convince them that they're just
simply wrong so maybe you do laugh off
the entire thing because it's an utterly
condescending way that could actually
show that there's a total absence of
logic and rationality laughter and
ridicule as the tactic instead of logic
and rationality and these types of
administration officials and candidates
they aren't based on logic and they're
not based on rationality so you can't
use those tools against them they care
about looking tough and acting tough and
imposing their view on others and
imposing their inaccurate views on
others so maybe just by laughing at them
you make them look silly and their ideas
hopefully go nowhere send me your
thoughts about the laughter technique
and do you think that it would be
effective not in change
their minds their minds aren't going to
be changed but in exposing the lack of
believability about the nonsense that
they're spewing to others to people in
the crowd to people who watch this stuff
on TV send me your thoughts about that
so I've said before I don't really
believe in using this type of language
as legitimate political language but but
it's sort of is the right language to
use here
Trump's been totally cooked by Vladimir
Putin and I know that Pat gets very very
upset when I use that kind of language
and he pulls me aside after the show and
we often have to have a conversation
that that embarrasses max because of how
crazy it gets but he's been totally cut
by Putin who has rejected Trump's
invitation to the White House into
Washington DC one of the things that
came out of the Helsinki summit other
than the sort of undeniable obvious
confirmation that Trump is a total
captive of Vladimir Putin's is that
Trump wants Putin at the White House
they were calling it a sort of second
summit but this time not on neutral
ground like Helsinki but rather on Putin
oh sorry
Freudian slip on Trump's turf Washington
DC in the United States and it wasn't
really clear whether this was a good
idea or a bad idea until yesterday when
Russia announced that they're gonna
reject the invitation they're rejecting
Trump's offer for a summit and it is
making Trump once again look like the
humiliated fool that he is getting
played by world leaders all over the
world and when you think about one of
Putin's top goals as meddling in the
2016 election to destabilize American
democracy and to make Russia seem like a
power player the Alpha around the world
this is the exact message that is
reinforced when Russia says Oh Trump
invited Putin to the White House
no thanks this isn't the right time and
for the time being
Russia is saying no Trump top Putin
Kremlin aide Yuri ochakov said quote
after the summit you know what kind of
atmosphere there is around its outcome I
think it would be wise to let the dust
settle and then we can discuss all these
questions in a businesslike way but not
now and this invitation was not some
random offhanded
statement from Trump just last week
Trump and White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said preparations
were already underway for the visit
right you don't say you're already
preparing for the visit unless you're
thinking about it as a serious thing and
now Putin says now can't be bothered
right now maybe some other time
Trump even tweeted about it last week
saying the summit with Russia was a
great success except with the real enemy
of the people the fake news media I look
forward to our second meeting so that we
can start implementing some of the many
things discussed including stopping
terrorism security for Israel nuclear
proliferation cyberattacks trade Ukraine
Middle East peace North Korea and more
there are many answers some easy and
some hard to these problems but they can
all be solved apparently not with Putin
at the White House though ouch totally
played once again right Putin is kind of
like the pickup artist
and Trump is the naive youngster who
thinks he's such a nice guy why wouldn't
I go on another date with I was thinking
that this was gonna stir up Trump's
daddy issues right I think Trump has one
of those complexes where his dad never
truly accepted him yeah so he was always
upset with himself right had to have his
dad bail him out so many times with his
business endeavors right I don't like
the same thing right if we think that
Trump is Putin working for Putin and yet
Putin won't even visit the White House
that's kind of shame him the art of the
deal this guy I mean can you think of a
worse deal maker than Trump in politics
Putin is just straight-up
toying with the guy but we got along so
well in Helsinki and now he says he
doesn't want to play in my sandbox how
many times from get humiliated by Putin
before the Trump is say enough is enough
this guy is embarrassing our country
unfortunately it's a very very high
number I don't think I don't think we're
anywhere close to the number of times
Trump needs to get humiliated by Putin
before the trumpets will say this might
not be working out as well as the so
called the renewed friendship with
Russia was supposed to be working out
the trumpets don't care they're gonna
stick with them it could have been
Russia who declined the information the
invitation it could have been Israel who
declined the invitation it could've been
a 400-pound man sitting on a bed
somewhere who listen there's nearly 200
countries out there so the fact that
Russia is not coming to Washington DC
could actually relate to Equatorial
Guinea's decision or maybe the Chilean
President made the call could be anybody
tons of countries out there as Donald
Trump often likes to say we have the
first casualty from Sacha Baron Cohen's
news show who is America Baron Cohen is
of course the actor who has developed
such characters as Ali G Borat Bruno and
in this new show that he has on Showtime
he plays a a new character he's an
Israeli firearms instructor named Iran
Murad who claims to support everything
from burka bands to training
four-year-olds to use firearms and he
has gotten some really high-profile
interviews Pat including everybody from
I don't even know where a standard
Sanders hiyo
Sarah Palin I think realized that
something wasn't right or she bailed Roy
Moore was interviewed by him and today
we have the first casualty which is
Jason Spencer Jason Spencer's a Georgia
state lawmaker he was apparently so
taken with kernel Iran Murad that he
ended up supporting a burqa ban yelling
the n-word incessantly pretending to be
an Asian tourists during which he
adopted a stereotypical Asian accent and
at one point actually dropped his pants
to quote use his buttocks to intimidate
Isis here is a piece of the video and
word warning but I think that his
buttocks is going to be blurred out for
people that are watching take a look at
this because of who you are you could be
the victim of kidnapping by Isis you
have two seconds to attract attention
how do you attract attention you start
screaming take your clothes off in
America there is one forbidden world it
is the N world now I am going to be the
terrorist you have three seconds to
attack the tension go you crazy
the N word is nuni not this world this
world is disgusting Janet
Isis are scared of being seen as Omo you
know it it mean Omo
if your buttock touch them it means they
have become a transsexual now I am going
to teach you how to use your buttocks to
intimidate Isis
show me the buttock no trousers down
okay go
good one more time
but louder with America we say in the
Mossad I mean not in the Mossad if you
want to win you show some skin ok ok
show it to me now try to touch me
I'll touch you touch you with my bags
now touch it you will drop the gun
I'll touch you you are say ok stop you
have to remind me if I touch you you
will become a homosexual
ok now try to touch me go go go
ok yes on you show me your weapon go oh
thank you homosexual you drop that gun
right now you I think the most
incredible thing is that when you watch
this clip
Spencer's behavior is so insane and so
outrageous that it's actually hard to
believe he's not an actor and that this
is all scripted it's so wack that it
seems like Spencer is working for the
show but he wasn't and he's now
resigning after this he is blaming Sasha
Baron Cohen saying that he was taking
advantage of he put out a statement
through the Atlanta journal-constitution
saying that quote in posing as an
Israeli agent Cohen pretended to offer
self-defense exercises as uncomfortable
as I was to participate I agreed to
understanding that these quote
techniques were meant to help me and
others fend off what I believed was an
inevitable attack I deeply regret the
language I used at Cohen's request as
well as my participation in the class
general if I had not been so distracted
by my fears I never would have agreed to
participate in the first place obviously
the first thing anybody does when they
believe that their family may be at risk
is you go somewhere and you start
yelling the N word out incessantly like
you're having a grand old party and he's
framed himself as just being so scared
that he was scared into participating
because of fear for his family imagine
just for a second okay here's what I was
thinking about Pat if you can get Jason
Spencer to say on camera the N word like
it's a party and fake an Asian accent
what is he willing to do behind the
scenes and what could a lobbyist get him
to do by offering him some money yeah I
mean he was totally exposed here right I
don't think I I think he does genuinely
believe these things deep down and would
say these things in private
I agree normally you wouldn't do that on
camera but he was duped here and I think
that's the genius of Sasha Baron Cohen
you're better off that Jason Spencer is
resigning now a lot of people do have a
problem with what Sasha Baron Cohen is
doing they're saying you you are
misrepresenting the person that you are
and thus the entire thing is sort of
dishonest at its base I don't know that
that's a good that could be an argument
against Sacha Baron Cohen's a format
right that how he does what he does with
Ali G Borat whoever but that's not a
defense of Jason Spencer because I don't
care what costume Sacha Baron Cohen puts
on I'm not gonna start yelling the N
word out incessantly right it just not
gonna happen I don't care what costume
or who he claims to be yeah I mean your
true colors are revealed here and some
people are failing the test others are
passing the test that's currently
Sanders for example he wasn't fooled by
it he could kind of pick up on the fact
that Sasha was playing a character and
even Sarah Palin and she as we're told
Sarah Palin identified that the person
claiming to be a so-called veteran of
the service was actually Sacha Baron
Cohen and was not a former service
member and walked out of the interview
not everybody is falling for this stuff
and we are all better off with Jason
Spencer resigning I think that there is
no question about that if you disagree
that Spencer should have to resign as a
result of this please let me know and
you can discuss it on the david pakman
show subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t what's been interesting
since Trump became president is the
number of Republicans who are willing to
go out there and say I disagree with the
President on this the president is wrong
about this jeff Flake john mccain susan
collins lisa murkowski
all of those people how lindsey graham
at one point marco rubio the other day
they're all willing to come out there
and say I disagree with the President on
issue X Y or Z or he took a wrong
approach to his summit with Putin
unfortunately none of these Republicans
aside from maybe giving a short
interview talking about how bad the
President did are actually willing to
stand up for him Lindsey Graham in the
early days of this administration
happened to be one of the biggest anti
Trump voices in the US Senate and then
he started going golfing with the
president and suddenly his tune changed
I mean it was almost overnight the guy
left the Golf Course and then started
talking about how great Donald Trump was
but then a few months went by no more
golf invites so he started going after
him a little bit more same thing with
Jeff Flake right Jeff Flake super loud
anti Trump guy and yet 16 different
times at least the Jeff Flake has said I
disagree with the President on this and
we cannot stand for it he's ended up
either backing down or voting or the
specific thing or person that he said
was so awful there is no real never
Trump Republican in Washington DC they
don't actually exist
what does exist is a cabal of
Republicans who understand that some of
them have to face reelection some of
them are ending their careers and don't
want to be looked upon negatively by the
American public either way they're
trying to do two things at once and one
is to give this public face of a person
who's not going to take it a person who
doesn't stand for what Trump stands for
but then we have the very private face
because after all let's let's be
perfectly honest here most Americans
don't go and check the voting records
you might see it occasionally come up in
a campaign
add so-and-so voted for this most of it
is shrouded in you know language that
paints it one way when in fact it's
another so nobody goes back and checks
the voting records or very few people do
not enough people do that gives these
never Trump Republicans the clearance to
say one thing publicly and they do a
different thing privately and that is
what we're seeing today and it's not
just they won't protect Muller it's not
just that they voted down the
congressional legislation that would
have prevented Donald Trump from
starting this trade war it's not just
that they won't let that interpreter
from that Putin meeting last week come
and testify before Congress it's all of
it these Republicans today have been
given so many opportunities to be heroes
I mean that's what they don't even
understand these guys could have been
the ones to save the day they could have
been the ones calling for that
interpreter from the Putin meaning to
come come to Congress they could have
been the ones to save the jobs that are
being lost now from the trade wars had
they acted but they don't and it's
because they're afraid they've seen
what's happened to Jeff Flake through
Donald Trump's Twitter attacks they've
seen what has happened to John McCain
through the the same Twitter attacks and
all that is his words neither of those
men have actually been punished in any
way by Donald Trump because he can't
actually do it he just goes on Twitter
makes fun of them people in his
administration make fun of them and
that's the end of it but even the threat
of just being made fun of by the
President on Twitter is enough to make
these Republicans completely complicit
with everything that this man has done
the only way to solve this problem is to
vote them out they're not going to come
around they're not going to suddenly
realize oh wait yeah I forgot to do
everything that I said I was going to do
against you it'll never happen
none of these Republicans are ever going
to be the heroes that we need them
to be even though they've had plenty of
opportunity to do it if they wanted to
they could have done it months ago
but every single one of them failed to
do it I'm fairing cousins and for David
Pakman today we'll be right back so
let's continue our discussion we've got
the NRA we've got this 29 year old
Russian agent named Maria boo Tina who's
now been indicted for working on behalf
of Russia in the United States without
being a registered foreign agent we have
a fewer of the david pakman show who
actually was at a class with Maria boo
Tina and exchanged emails with her and
he sent them to me and I've been
reviewing them and I don't know whether
they they're really relevant for the
show I don't know if he's okay with me
showing them to you but I've been
reviewing a lot of the activity that
Maria boo Tina has been involved in and
she appears to be at least one of the
conduits between the Russians and the
Trump campaign via the NRA and that's a
connection that we've been following for
months so I already told you in the last
story that the same day of Maria boo
Tina's indictment the Trump Treasury
headed by Steven minuchin decided to
change a rule to make it easier to hide
the donors of dark money to
organizations just like the NRA
convenient coincidence okay
well yesterday we learned that it wasn't
just the NRA that Maria boo Tina was
meeting meeting with it wasn't just
showing up at a trump event and asking
Trump a question about easing Russian
sanctions but Reuters is now reporting
that Maria boo Tina also met with two
senior officials at the United States
Federal Reserve and the Treasury
Department along with other visiting
Russian officials I'm not saying these
things are related but this thinks
really really badly and it now also
pulls in specifically Alexander tortion
who happens to be the exact Russian rich
dude who's already suspected of being a
funder of trumps campaign via the NRA
multiple people familiar with the
meetings involving boo Tina and the
Treasury and the Fed have confirmed that
including Americans who are connected to
those meetings so there is nothing being
questioned about whether these meetings
took place so
consider what we now know with regard to
Maria boo Tina number one Maria boo Tina
met with high-ranking NRA officials and
of course we know that the NRA was
funneling money to the Trump campaign
number two
Maria boo Tina met with US Treasury and
Federal Reserve officials number three
the Treasury relaxed reporting
requirements of NRA donor information
within 48 hours of Maria boo Tina's
arrest and number four boo Tina worked
for NRA tied poutin connected Russian
Alexander tortion I also increasingly
don't understand how a twenty-something
year old Russian gets meeting after
meeting with NRA higher up Treasury
higher up Federal Reserve higher up and
nobody seems to raise an eyebrow and the
broader picture here is twofold number
one we now realize that Russia deployed
the full spectrum of infiltration
techniques you have Russians teasing
Trump campaign officials and Trump's own
family including Donald Trump jr. and
Kushner with dirt on Hillary and it got
them meetings at Trump Tower
you have the messing with the voting
systems by Russia in something like
twenty or more states and actually
accessing the voting systems in at least
one state as far as the latest reports
indicate you have infiltration of
traditionally right-wing organizations
like the NRA and the use of those
organizations as conduits to both the
Republican Party's easing of their
position on Russia and to the Trump
campaign itself and then lastly and some
people don't like this we don't know to
what extent Maria boo Tina may have used
sex to obtain even more than we know
about right so like it's not it's not
sexist to say that Maria boo Tina may
have used sex in order to develop some
of the connections that she did it's
just a widely used tactic by Russia and
other intelligence services and it's one
of the reasons why a
a woman operating in a world that is
disproportionately men granting access
it wouldn't be shocking to think that
that may be why this 20-something woman
with no real credentials to speak uh was
able to get this level of access and
it's it's not sexist and in fact I don't
even know if we need to call it
infiltration when it seems like many of
these parties the Trump campaign the
Republican Party the NRA among others
willingly welcomed Maria boo Tina so
we're going to learn some incredible
things in the next few months this is
only the start and I really do want to
hear from our from the audience
particularly from the Russia skeptics on
this when you see the various modes of
infiltration that took place working
directly with the Trump campaign working
through conduits like the NRA and others
using individuals like Maria boo Tina to
meet with folks at everywhere from the
Federal Reserve and the Treasury to the
NRA how at this point can anybody still
be a so-called Russia skeptic let me
know this is a topic of discussion on
the David Pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t and we've
got a fantastic program for you today
you don't have to pretend that iran was
a sensible moderate democratic regime to
admit the truth which is that the obama
iran deal has actually worked out pretty
well for years at this point and i was a
critic of some aspects of that deal when
it was first signed but i was overall a
supporter of the deal and in fact when i
was on fox news last week the right-wing
guests as well as the host who kind of
teamed up on me we're arguing that
donald trump deserves credit for nine
months without a North Korean missile
test and if that's true then when it
comes to the Iran deal clearly President
Obama deserved and arguably still
deserves credit for year after year
after year over Iran not testing nukes
and not doing nuclear advancement and
not violating the terms of that deal and
what we now have is Iran threatening war
against the United States and
threatening Donald Trump specifically
with what they're calling
the mother of all wars after Donald
Trump has become increasingly hostile to
Iran and on his position with regard to
the Iranian regime including the recent
announcement which we covered
extensively about Donald Trump planning
to pull out of the Iran nuclear deal
even though as far as we know as far as
inspectors know as far as the checks and
balances that exist as part of that deal
Iran hasn't violated the terms of the
deal so there's a few different layers
of analysis here number one big picture
remember that it was Hillary Clinton who
we were told was going to get us into
Wars but here is yet another country
with which Donald Trump is inching
closer to a war so let's get to what the
Iranian president said and of course
Donald Trump has responded as he often
does on Twitter Iran's president Hassan
rouhani saying yesterday quote don't
play with fire or you will regret
Iranian people are the master and they
will never bow to anyone America should
no peace with Iran is the mother of all
peace but he later threatened in the
statement that war with Iran is the
mother of all wars and of course Donald
Trump predictably and this may even have
been a calculated decision by Iran
knowing that Donald Trump is unable to
resist acting like a normal person
because he's not one and Trump
immediately responding exactly as we
would expect on Twitter with more
threats saying to Iranian president
rouhani never it is all in caps by the
way if you're if you're not looking at
this never ever threaten the United
States again or you will suffer
consequences the likes of which few
throughout history have ever suffered
before we are no longer a country I
guess that's a reference to Obama that
will stand for your demented words of
violence and death be cautious this is
an issue where the right is probably
going to successfully turn it around and
say things like look this is proof that
Iran is unhinged and belligerent and so
we should get out of the Iran deal and
Trump is right to be tough with them and
of course they'll accuse the left and me
of being soft and wanting to cower in
fear as Iran threatens war know you're
deliberately misunderstanding this if
that's what you think I'm saying I have
been abundantly clear
that Iran is a belligerent unhinged
theocracy with an increasingly secular
young population that doesn't want
conflict with the United States right
that that's what's going on in Iran we
had a good thing going we had a deal not
a perfect deal but a pretty good deal
and as long as the United States kept up
its end meaning you stay in the deal if
Iran doesn't violate it then we have
leverage over them if they go rogue in
other words if we do our part and stay
in the deal and Iran goes rogue violates
that deal now we actually have political
capital to spend when it comes to a
response but now in comes Trump wants to
undo anything with Barack Obama's name
on it including the Iran deal and that
is going now out of the way to provoke
Iran in addition to threatening quote
the strongest sanctions in history when
Iran hasn't violated the deal so I'm
here saying if Iran does something in
violation of the deal then the u.s. is
actually in a better position to
retaliate we could debate at that time
what is the retaliation that trump wants
and does that make sense but at least we
can say Iran violated the deal now there
can be repercussions but whenever on is
cooperated to the extent that we can
check and the u.s. simply says now we're
out Obama was wrong to do the deal we're
gonna put on the strongest sanctions in
history that is irrational hostility
towards Iran and I'm not saying Iran
doesn't deserve sanctions I'm not saying
Iran is a geopolitical partner to be
trusted they are not a geopolitical
partner to be trusted but if you have
something that appears to be keeping
them less escalated and agitated and the
Iran deal seemed to be doing that build
on it rather than destroy it and Iran is
an extremist nation like many others we
have to deal with if you've gotten more
control if you've gotten them more under
control than others then maybe focus
elsewhere right focus on Russian active
measures again instead of rewarding
Russia further
behavior or focus on Saudi Arabia's
extremist regime instead of selling them
weapons or work on getting some
concessions from Israel instead of
moving the embassy to Jerusalem right
don't go out of your way to anger Iran
for no reason whatsoever as far as the
people who are skipping the geopolitics
because there are people who are
ignoring the fact that we are causing
Iran to escalate by virtue of the
haphazard pulling out of the Iran deal
or announcement of the pulling out of
the Iran deal threats of the strongest
sanctions ever skipping the geopolitics
there are some people who are going to
bring it on and we can destroy Iran in a
war Iran has nothing honest militarily
yeah our military is much bigger than
Iran's but Iran is in Iraq Iran has a
massive military compared to Iraq and
war with Iran would be a completely
different thing than Iraq I'm not saying
the United States would quote lose but
you have to remember that in quote
winning against Iraq if you believe that
we did we suffered 4,000 or more
American servicemember casualties likely
a hundred thousand or more Iraqi
civilians died and the idea that there's
going to be anything even remotely
similar if we were to go with Iran is an
absolute and total joke but I actually
don't think that's the right
conversation now the correct
conversation is why is Trump ruining
something that was at least going okay
and going better than it had been for
years and the fear the threat now
becomes is Trump more unhinged by these
threats then Iran is by our backing out
of the nuclear deal and does Trump start
to proactively plan for or push for or
drive to war with Iran and if he is
who's going to stop him
we know he wanted to go to war with
Venezuela and he was talked out of it we
know that he was starting to get
belligerent about military action
against North Korea unfortunately that
hasn't happened I don't know if we can
count on chief of staff John Kelly
because he's increasingly at odds with
Trump Stephen Miller is not going to
talk Trump out of a war with Iran is
john bolton going to talk trump out of a
war with iran this is why we have to be
extraordinarily concerned and remember
supposedly it was Hillary who was going
to get us him to multiple Wars it's
Trump who's been pushing for multiple
Wars behind the scenes I have been
telling you about the Orwellian Newspeak
that has been scaling up from Trump and
the administration lately they're making
claims that aren't just inaccurate but
the are they're the exact opposite of
reality in many cases and I've said it
before and I'll say it again this is a
strategy and this is a strategy to make
people question whether they can believe
anything that they hear at all and we've
talked about the dynamics of how that
works before if Trump says I don't know
pick a topic stormy Daniels I don't know
who she is I met her we didn't pay
anything we paid but it was Cohen's
money but I didn't pay him back but I
did pay him back all of a sudden it
becomes sort of like a non-issue in the
mind of Trumpets because they've heard
every possible side of that issue
espoused by Donald Trump at least at
some point they don't know what to
believe they'll go back to seeing the
Red Sox Yankee game instead and then not
worry anymore about what actually is the
truth about stormy Daniels Trump is now
using this strategy on Trump Russia he
is now claiming that he's worried that
Russia will meddle in the 2018 midterms
to help Democrats this is straight-up
concern trolling check out Trump's tweet
from yesterday where he said quote I'm
very concerned that Russia will be
fighting very hard to have an impact on
the upcoming election yeah okay well
that part's true
and he goes on to say based on the fact
that no president has been tougher on
Russia than me they will be pushing very
hard for the Democrats they definitely
don't want Trump
now of course none of that is true
there's no evidence that Russia is
trying to help Democrats Trump certainly
hasn't been the toughest president on
Russia and all the evidence is that
Russia does want Trump now I do want to
say okay before we get onto like the
bulk of the analysis Russia's goals are
broader than Trump per se so Trump is a
means to an end he makes the u.s. look
terrible he makes Putin look better and
stronger in comparison he destabilizes
American democracy and makes people
question whether our democratic system
is even working it's possible that drop
Russia would help Democrats like if
Russia determined that that would be the
next thing like if Russia determined
that okay Trump we help Trump win and
and things are crazy let's now create
even more chaos by helping Democrats
achieve a majority and a House senator
both because of how it will further
unhinge Trump that is how Russia thinks
there's just no evidence that that's
actually going on right now oh yeah I
mean it's pretty clear that in 2012 they
favored Barack Obama over Mitt Romney
right but in 2016 what do you mean by
that well Romney was pretty tough on
Russia and oh yeah they liked Obama more
fair enough but in the recent Helsinki
summit Putin said that he wanted Trump
to win right because that would normally
is normalized relations between the US
and Russia so this is gaslighting that's
ultimately what it is this is another
example of projection it's Orwellian
Newspeak where everything is the
opposite and this is now something that
someone is feeding Donald Trump I
actually don't think that Trump is
coming up with this himself anymore I
think that somebody is feeding to Trump
take the line that Russia wants the Dems
to win and this is also another de facto
attack on American intelligence by the
way Trump's not saying it in his tweet
and Trump's tweet he just says Russia
wants the Dems but we know that the
consensus of the intelligence community
is that Russia metal to help Trump when
Trump says the opposite when Trump says
I've been super tough on Russia and
Russia wants the Dems that's sort of a
de facto way of Trump saying he doesn't
believe the intelligence community and
this is monstrous dangerous gaslighting
and it's only dangerous because people
will believe it and will be tricked by
it period if we had a voting public
overall that saw this and said that's
not true we know what the truth is and
this isn't it it wouldn't be so
dangerous but it's dangerous because
there are a lot of people out there who
are gonna believe this stuff and if we
needed more proof that Trump isn't
really worried about Russia hacking the
Democrats hacking to help Democrats
rather it's that he's doing nothing
about it right think about this for a
second if your Trump or if you're a
Republican and you want Republicans to
win and you think Russia's helping
Democrats you would immediately try to
stop Russian meddling Trump hasn't tried
to stop Russian meddling and in fact he
said just last week how strong and tough
Putin was in his denials that meddling
even took place and additionally
Republicans just blocked a bid
- a bill Wrather to extend election
security grants if you run the House and
Senate and you think Russia is helping
the Democrats why would you block
funding for election security you would
say hey we need to stop it because
Russia wants the Dems none of them
believe that that's what's going on or
those additional sanctioned over
positions overwhelmingly passed by
Congress that Trump for the longest time
refused to implement it was today in
trying to implement them it's not insane
to say we can imagine why Russia might
want Democrats to win over Republicans
we could we could imagine that
circumstance but there's no evidence
that that's going on it goes completely
counter to what our intelligence
agencies are saying and three if anybody
believes that that's what Russia is
doing they're doing nothing to try to
prevent it which is what makes it
abundantly clear that this is a show
it's a gong show
it's a joke and more importantly it's
working I was trolling some of the not
actually I wasn't posting anything but I
was sort of browsing some of the known
internet enclaves of the most committed
Trumpets and they are they are now
saying Russia wants the Democrats Russia
wants the Democrats to win and we need
to vote in November because otherwise
Russia and the Dems will take the House
and Senate so it's working any
harebrained notion that is presented by
Trump is now being taken as gospel by
trumpet and that's why this stuff is so
abundantly dangerous